this is a bit different for a 60 symbols
video in that actually it's sort of meta
video in that it's not actually about
science it's about 60 symbols itself
and the exciting news is that there is
the opportunity for somebody new to get
involved in the whole project somebody
to come and join the team start making
some of the videos start doing some
science the whole point of this series
is that they're kind of bits of science
being described by scientists and so we
do want somebody who is a professional
scientist getting involved in this but
what's a bit different about it is that
you'll notice most of the people doing
the videos are getting on a bit these
days we've been doing them for a while
and so what's exciting about this is
we're gonna get somebody at a much
earlier stage in a scientific career
involved in the whole project so that
not only can they talk about the science
but obviously one of the questions we
get asked quite a lot of the time is
what's it like to be starting out in a
career in science for us that was all a
fair while ago so having somebody who's
actually going through that process now
can talk about what it's like to be
starting in a career in science as well
as talking about the science itself is
part of what we're trying to do so it's
called the 60 symbols ogden fellowship
is what we've managed to create and the
there are different parts of that so
let's start at the back end fellowship
basically means this is a post-doctoral
researcher who can do whatever they like
so it's kind of the distinction between
uh just a general postdoc and a fellow
is that fellows really dictate their own
research program so we want somebody to
come in who's got exciting ideas about
what science they want to be doing
anywhere within physics or astronomy
this is a real research position you
know it's going to be two-thirds of the
time doing research third of the time
maybe doing outreach type things but
it's fundamentally a proper research
position and a very exciting opportunity
because as i say the person who's coming
in really will get to to define what
their research program is so that's the
fellowship bit the bit in the middle uh
with the beginning is 60 symbols that's
the easy bit the bit in the middle the
ogden bit is because obviously this
takes money and we've been looking
around trying to find somebody to
support this idea
and the ogden trust which is a
charitable trust that kind of promotes
physics in the uk
has
agreed to fund partly fund the position
um so part of the job will actually be
supporting kind of the ogden trusts
agenda of getting out into the community
talking about physics encouraging groups
of people who don't typically go into
scientific careers to go into scientific
careers what are they going to have to
do with 60 symbols or do we well i guess
i have some say in that too you probably
get to say a bit about that i mean
my initial idea was really that they
just they fit in with the team so they
start making the kind of videos that we
make generally obviously they'll bring
their own particular interests so
hopefully some new areas of physics that
we haven't been covering um but also to
talk more generally about what they're
up to what it's like to be doing the job
that they're doing um you know when they
start applying for their own funding and
those kinds of things they can talk
about all that just talking about things
from that early career perspective that
the rest of us don't really have they'll
feature in the videos and you know if
they have particular skills they want to
bring to bear that we don't currently
use then that would be fine too
so it is a post doctoral position which
means that one of the requirements of
the post is you have to have a phd um
that's that's really it though um and so
we're looking for somebody who's
probably just at the point of completing
a phd now or completed it within the
last year or so who's looking for their
first serious research position i wanted
an astronomer but that's just because
i'm an astronomer and if you talk to
phil moriarty he wants a you know a nice
nanotechnologist so i'm sure we all have
our own ideas exactly who the right
person for the job is but there is no
there is no there is no set person
though is there there is no real no
there's no agenda no hidden agenda here
we haven't got somebody lined up already
it's a completely open competition when
we're appointing postdoctoral
researchers the main thing we look at is
you know their cv and publicationists
and all those kinds of things we're
going to ask for all those
those things but obviously this is a bit
different and so the other thing we're
asking people to do
is to make a video themselves
uh no more than two minutes duration
just explaining some piece of science
they do not really not necessarily in
the style of 60 symbols but kind of
about the level of sexy symbols so just
to kind of demonstrate they have that
ability to explain what they're doing in
the kind of way that we explain things
and the other thing to stress about that
is when we come to kind of assess those
videos we're not going to look at the
technical quality
um you know assuming the video is
viewable and this sounds audible and
those kinds of things we're really not
going to be critiquing them because you
know we have an entirely adequate
cameraman
the position is funded for two years so
it's a two-year position
obviously we're hoping that it'll be a
huge success and everyone will be
falling all over themselves to continue
funding it but it will be guaranteed for
two years at least you know there's lots
of reasons why we're excited about this
it's a new thing we're pushing the
project in new directions um it's an
opportunity to do some new science and i
guess what's most exciting about that is
it's an opportunity to do new science
that wouldn't have happened at all if it
wasn't for 60 symbols so actually the
science that comes out of this is
science that wouldn't have been done if
it weren't for the 60 symbols videos um
so which i think is really quite an
exciting aspect of the whole thing
yeah
me too
to vastly restrict the amount of light
coming in to isolate exactly the
wavelengths that we want so it turns our
wide filter into a filter with a width
of just a nanometer or so
and it's tunable so it's got two little
plates inside a reflecting material